the Joe Rogan experience you're one of
those dudes that has that book cover for
your phone I tried to rock the book
cover
after why I'm like what am I doing here
with this extra step where I got to open
up a book to get to my phone I like it
because I forget things a lot so like I
don't like having a wallet and a phone
when I leave somewhere like especially
even in the house I leave the house in
my phone but I don't have my cash on the
cards so I got a solution for you it's
called that's right you're cool dude you
think you're cool enough to rock one of
these like are you cool enough to get
past the social pariah aspect of this
bag that you wear around your waist I
don't have that much [ __ ] with me most
of the time it's not that much [ __ ]
there's a lot of [ __ ] in here but this
is a weird day I've like keys and I have
a knife in there and stuff but most of
the time it's just light a travel light
with that look at that whose get who's
that like quavo from Miko's I've no idea
who you just said popular rapping but
that is a ridiculous I know I'm an old
man who listens to the Allman Brothers
alright but that one that he's got on is
preposterous you might as well have a
laptop hanging around its way he's also
good like holding his jeans yeah that's
ridiculous would you get attacked by a
tiger sir jewelry all that jewelry in
the 80s yeah he's kind of ridiculous
looking go but but make that make that
bigger again so I'm gonna take a look at
this gentleman light version - I
probably could have found a better place
he's got a lot going on those pants are
preposterous that's the most
preposterous thing like I guess the
shoes if you're like you want to go out
but you also want to go bowling you
might wear those shoes this is a roast
vest let's go I can't say anything bad
about the jewelry I'm not into the
jewelry I mean I mean that's not my
thing but he looks like he's well
appointed I guess two watches on though
[ __ ] yeah ballin hashtag ballin I think
the one on the right is probably just is
that a Ray slit bracelet yeah it's just
a fancy ass bracelet but the pants are
ridiculous I don't know how the [ __ ] did
that ever get started where people wear
ripped up pants I try to talk to Brennan
shop about that that dumb [ __ ]
wears those [ __ ]
going on for a while music videos just
like what are you doing man
it's like Pat Benatar I don't have any
fashion taste don't listen to me but
when I mock some [ __ ] you might want to
listen to me like don't wear what I wear
like you know don't don't I mostly wear
either love wear like these things which
are like trail running sneakers they get
no sneaker cred or I'll wear like
converse allstar I'll get this look at
this teen beat Donnie Wahlberg yeah
exactly from the 90s this is hard not
just slip right out of that one oh right
right hand side that one on the right
hand side come on silly [ __ ] you saw the
like I don't know I see that and I feel
like the guys were probably wearing a
thong under that too yeah I would
imagine there's something going on now
see like with the women like it's so
much nicer yeah right now this is where
I'm a hypocrite like would Beyonce right
there she fills it out yeah she's a dot
see that's kind of different because
like a woman's legs and everything are
very sexual right so you see extra leg
it's like just shut your mouth and take
the bonus yeah right yeah you don't want
to complain about it but a dude wearing
something like that it's like it's it's
literally like well not literally but
it's so much like a guy wearing a dress
like it's a fashion for women I believe
it's trying way too hard like this look
at this fella he this like seems like
the eighties though cuz he's got a
jacket on I mean you can look at the
quality of picture yeah right that's
trim that hairstyle the suit suit
jackets never came back though he's got
patches yeah I remember when they used
to do all that art on the jeans - mmm
those pants are ridiculous but ripped up
pants men allegedly gripped up pants
inand and skinny jean I'm like I'm still
100% against skinny jeans you know what
I say that I'm against gain jeans but I
wear these things called barbell jeans
you ever wear those no they look like
skinny jeans because they're tight to
you but they have oh this is they're
made out of yeah [ __ ]
they got some some elasticity yeah man
they're like we're in sweatpants like
you don't fit they don't feel you go
throw kicks in them like you could like
for real I'm too old
[Applause]